في اخر اسبوعين كانت تجي كل دقيقه
ادعيلي
الحمد لله رب العالمين
كان حكايات حاسه
[موسيقى]
مدرسه طب سنه اولى كان نفسي اسعد اختي
قبل ما تموت
كنا انا وياه على المكتب وقاعده بتفرج على
الصور بتحكي لي هذا مخنا بحكي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
كانت بتحب الطن
[ضحك]
دايما
[موسيقى]
تروح من الجامع مصروفها سته
كانت تروح تتسبب فيهم بتحكي لي هذا بيني
وبينك وبين ربنا ما تخليش من اهلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كنت انا جنب بابا
وكانت غيرانه وهي غيرها
وقعدات ترقص كان في صدام ترقص وتغيظ فيها
[موسيقى]
الصدمه كانت فوق الخيال الصغير شاف بنت
عمه بدمها غرقانه على الدرج
هذا طفل من شوف ايش عندي هذا ايش البيت
التاني ايش البيت الثاني ايش بيوت مقليه
من ورا هذا الحدث
[موسيقى]
هي بتحكي لي انا بعرف ابني